c'était la réunion de la dernière chance
et apparemment le fil du dialogue et
renault est pas moins de quatre
ministres recevait les syndicats
enseignants cet après midi le
gouvernement a fait des concessions sur
la décentralisation il renonce à
certains transferts de personnels stefan
grand salah graby ils sont arrivés par
petites grappes bien avant l'heure comme
de bons élèves sauf que les 110
enseignants continuent de donner des
sueurs froides au gouvernement le tombé
face à bien sûr à deux jours du bac de
philo continuer la lutte ou sortir du
coin fille la tête haute
telle pourrait être la problématique du
jour premiers éléments de réponse
nous sommes opposés à tout boycott du
monde quel que soit le résultat de cette
politique tableau on crucial quatre
ministres face aux syndicats et nicolas
sarkozy dans le rôle du démineur
il y a urgence une heure trente de
discussions en cours et au final
quelques avancées 80 millions d'euros
débloqués mais de nombreux points de
friction sur la décentralisation et les
retraites notamment copie à revoir
disent en choeur les syndicats comme fo
fut notamment en matière budgétaire
il n'y a rien sur les chauraisiens donc
il ya des bouger mais le compte n'y est
pas et pour nous ça signifie qu'il va
falloir écrire
et le baccalauréat dans tout ça les
syndicats ont rappelé qu'il
n'appellerait pas au boycott ce qui a
semble-t-il quelque peu soulagé c'est
les ministres négociateurs sur la
méthode qui était proposée par le
gouvernement et le calendrier qui a été
fixé à été me semble-t-il accepté par
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
c'est donc une bonne journée un pas en
avant qui ne résout pas tous les
problèmes bien sûr mais qui je crois est
de nature à amener de la sérénité dans
une situation qui en avait bien besoin
une bonne journée pas sûr car des
actions ponctuelles de la base notamment
sont toujours possibles
seule certitude le malaise persiste à
l'éducation nationale